[Musique]
j'avais prévu de vous faire une blague
on peut vous promet qu'elle était drôle
mais avec toute l'émotion que j'ai reçus
ne parle et aucun de mes prédécesseurs
j'arrive plus à la faire en plus de ça
je me suis rendu compte que l'équipe de
t d que ce n'est pas beaucoup parce que
pour me faire passer après ces personnes
je pense qu'il faut faut pas avoir envie
de voir ma réussite
je ne sais pas pour vous mais moi j'ai
toujours aimé aller vers les autres
savoir ce qu'ils font connaître leur
histoire
je trouve beaucoup d'inspiration dans
l'histoire des autres
un peu comme dans les livres en plus de
ça j'ai toujours été très curieux et
sociable tout petit déjà je passais mon
temps à poser des questions à mes
parents mes oncles mes tantes
dès que j'en avais l'occasion à cela
s'ajoute le fait que j'adore voyager
les premiers voyages pour moi si tu es
au village en famille mes deux parents
sont issus d'un petit village à l'est du
burkina à 500km de ouaga et il fallait
partir très tôt le matin
si on voulait espérer arriver avant la
nuit vu l'état de la route et surtout de
tous les arrêts qu'on avait à faire
ces vingt dernières années j'ai eu la
chance d'habiter sur trois continents
différents et de visiter une trentaine
de pays
ce soir si vous le permettez j'aimerais
partager avec vous ce que ces voyages
ont apportés et surtout à quel point il
me rapprocher de chez moi bonsoir à tous
nisa b good evening in jura là je
m'appelle jouahri j'ai 32 ans et je suis
fièrement burkinabè
le voyage le plus marquant pour moi
c'était à l'été 99 le 12 juillet
exactement pour les amoureux du foot
comme moi un an plus tôt la france
devenait championne du monde de football
grâce à deux coups tête magnifique de
zidane
ce même coup tête leur coûtera la finale
du mondial 2006 ce voyage était marquant
car en fait c'était un déménagement pour
ma famille et moi il s'agissait de
quitter notre burkina bien aimée pour la
france car un avenir meilleur nous était
promise
une des premières choses qui m'a choqué
en arrivant dès l'aéroport c'était les
distributeurs automatiques de boissons
je ne comprenais pas pourquoi on
laissait des boissons en libre service
parce que pour moi de plus gourmands
allaient tous boire bon il faut noter
qu'à l'époque j'étais très gourmand et
que j'ai passé mon temps à boire le
temps que nos bagages arrivent mais ma
plus grande surprise c'était mon
quartier lorsque vous avez 12 ans que
vous quittez le burkina pour la france
vous vous attendez à voir des blancs
partout et des noirs nulle part dans mon
quartier il en avait deux des blancs
notamment il y en avait deux mais en
plus de ça ils ont très vite déménager
et au fil des années nous sommes
retrouvés entre français d'origine
immigrée
mes voisins étaient donc algérien
congolais marocain ivoirien tuque et
j'en passe avec du recul c'était génial
d'avoir cette diversité de personnes
autour de moi car sans même le savoir
j'avais commencé à voyager à travers les
interactions que je trouvais à voir avec
ces personnes
en plus de cela il avait une grande
solidarité entre nous malgré nos
différences un peu comme au burkina
néanmoins ça restait un choc culturel et
émotionnel pour moi car beaucoup de
choses étaient différentes
le fait d'être resté aussi loin de
médecine aussi longtemps avait changé
beaucoup de choses en moi par exemple
lorsque j'étais au burkina j'aimais
beaucoup l'école une fois en france je
préférais traîner dehors avec mes potes
plutôt qu'aller en cours naturellement
j'ai joué au bac
je n'ai pas échoué une fois mais deux
fois
aujourd'hui je vous en parler
ouvertement
mais pendant plusieurs années j'avais
honte de moi non seulement j'avais honte
de moi mais j'avais surtout en vis-à-vis
de mes parents pour qui l'école
représente et où j'avais été celui qui
avait la chance d'aller en france pour
faire ses études et j'étais juste en
train de tout gâcher
en plus de ça à la suite de mes deux
échecs j'ai décidé d'arrêter l'école
sans que personne ne le sache
je sortais tous les matins prétextant
aller en cours alors qu'en fait j'allais
travailler dans un centre commercial à
côté de la maison maman quand tu verras
cette vidéo pardonne moi s'il te plaît
par la force des choses je me suis
repris j'ai fini par avoir mon bac
vous avez le droit de m'applaudir je
vous remercie
il ya un peu moins de 10 ans alors que
je venais d'obtenir mon premier diplôme
d'études supérieures je me suis mis à la
recherche d'un stage j'ai beaucoup aimé
mes études supérieures puisque j'ai eu
la chance d'étudier dans une école avec
plus de 50 nationalités différentes
ce diplôme représentait beaucoup pour
moi de par mon échec au bac mais surtout
parce que cette fois ci j'avais été un
genre de ma promo j'étais intimement
convaincu que cet atout allez m'ouvrir
les portes du monde professionnel
mais en fait il n'en fut rien il m'a
fallu six mois pour enfin trouver un
stage ces six mois m'ont paru une
éternité et ont représenté une vraie
torture pour moi surtout que mes potes
de promo eux avaient tous trouvé des
stages au bout d'un mois je me remettais
en question
j'ai essayé de me retourner vers
certaines personnes mais le résultat
était le même
je compte que ce n'était pas forcément
moins le problème le problème c'est que
je ne connaissais personne personne qui
ne plus me guider dans mes recherches
personnes qui ne puisse pas assister
dans la rédaction de mon six personnes
qu'ils ne puissent orienter personnes en
fait qui ne puisse m'offrir une
opportunité professionnelle
laissez moi vous raconter une histoire
l'entreprise dans laquelle j'ai
finalement effectuer mon stage était
l'une des 3 plus grandes banques
françaises investissement nos quartiers
étaient situés dans le quartier
d'affaires de nos bureaux pardon était
situé dans le quartier d'affaires de la
défense dans une tour de plusieurs
dixièmes des tâches il nous n'étions pas
moins de dix mille employés
je m'en souviendrai toujours parce qu'à
chaque fois que je sortais du métro j'ai
passé mon temps à observer la rue et de
personnes habillées en costard-cravate
allant vers les tours et j'essayais
d'imaginer quel était leur métier
c'était impressionnant et surtout
inspirant dans l'autre
tour nous avions une grande cafétéria
une énorme cantine
j'adorais la cantine parce qu on y
mangeait souvent des choses qu'on
mangeait pas à la maison
c'était comme un genre de restaurant
pour stagiaires et puis c'était pas cher
plus sérieusement à la raison pour
laquelle j'aime et la cantine
c'était parce que c'est le seul endroit
où nous étions tous assis à la même
table et surtout parce que j'adorais
observer ce qui s'y passe et j'ai été
frappé par un phénomène que je ne
m'explique est pas dans cette cantine et
avait une table qui n'a pas arrêté de se
remplir au field au fil de l'année
au début ils étaient 3 autour de cette
table six mois après ils étaient 10 et à
la fin de l'année il était vain jusque
là rien d'anormal si ce n'est que les
trois du début était toujours là la fin
et que les autres avaient rejoint la
table un peu au compte-gouttes un peu
comme s'ils s'étaient passé le mot pour
se faire recruter
c'était une table de sénégalais la table
avait même été rebaptisée dakar ensuite
j'ai compris que ces sénégalais là se
passait effectivement le mot se faire
recruter afin d'avoir des postes au sein
de l'entreprise
il y avait une énorme solidarité
professionnelle entre ces personnes en
voyant ça et en faisant la comparaison
avec ma situation je me suis demandé
pourquoi est ce que nous pour keane ab
ne fonctionne pas ainsi
pourquoi s'il n'y avait pas une table de
burkinabè
bon on aurait peut-être les t2 mais au
moins en vivant ça quelques années après
cet échec dans ma recherche de stage est
également cette solitude dans mon
ascension professionnelle j'ai décidé de
quitter la france
en france j'avais l'impression que tout
ce que je pensais pouvoir faire était
réservée aux autres j'avais l'impression
que tout était déjà créé al avance pour
moi alors que ce n'était pas l'histoire
que j'avais choisi d'écrire
j'avais l'impression comme empêcher de
rêver en parlant de rêve étant plus
jeune j'avais toujours rêvé de vivre aux
états unis
j'en rêvais à cause des films et des
clips afro-américains qu'on n'arrêtait
pas de regarder avec un et cousins on
avait l'impression que c'était le seul
endroit sur terre où les noirs pouvaient
réussir leur vie
j'avais eu la chance d'y aller en
vacances mais cette fois ci c'était
différent parce que j'allais y vivre et
y passer les moments les plus profonds
de ma vie de jeune adulte sauf que ça je
ne le savait pas encore c'est très
bizarre pour moi parce que j'étais
partagé par plusieurs sentiments rejeté
à la fois excité comme un gosse devant
un nouveau jouet est triste triste de
devoir quitter ma famille qui
représentait tout pour moi surtout que
nous traversions une situation très
délicate mais ma décision était prise je
voulais partir car je ne me sentais plus
à ma place j'ai donc pris mon courage à
deux mains et j'ai atterri à new york
alors autant vous dire tout de suite que
je n'ai pas arrêté montréal américains
parce que je ne suis pas devenu
millionnaire mais j'ai réalisé mon rêve
pour qui n'avait il s'est passé quelque
chose qui a tout changé
j'ai fait une rencontre où devrais le
dire j'ai fait une retrouvaille il se
trouvait que dans cette même ville de
new york
vivez un ami d'enfance c'est vraiment
parce que dans mes souvenirs ne l'est
toujours pas très proche nous avions
fait la même classe ici au collège de la
salle avant que je ne quitte le burkina
et à l'époque les avait ni facebook ni
instagram et j'en passe c'est ainsi que
quinze ans après je revoyais mon ami et
nous avons reconnecter comme si nous
étions jamais quitté je ne saurais pas
vous l'expliquer
en tant que bon burkinabè et de
surprendre mais aussi cet ami à dorer la
viande est la première chose qu'il a
fait c'est qui m'a invité dans un
restaurant coréen spécialisé dans la
viande de poulet et c'était très bon
d'ailleurs cet ami contrairement à moi
avait gardé un fort lien avec le burkina
et les burkinabè il était même membre
d'une association de burkinabè à new
york est très actif grâce à lui je me
suis mis à rencontrer des burkinabè
oui j'ai rencontré des burkinabè car
autant vous dire que pour rencontrer des
burkinabè
en dehors du burkina comme l'expression
aime à le dire ici il faut les chercher
avec une torche
je ne sais pas pour vous mais moi j'ai
l'impression que les burkinabè se cache
lorsqu'ils sont à l'étranger
non seulement ils se cachent mais en
plus de ça il ne s'affirme pas et c'est
un point où on les confond avec d'autres
nationalités
par exemple moi quand je vivais en
france on me prenait pour un ivoirien
il fallait que j'insiste pour affirmer
ma nationalité burkinabè
quand j'ai déménagé aux états unis
j'étais devenu nigérian il fallait même
pas leur parler du burkina parce que la
minute d'après vous les avez perdu ces
rencontres ont tout changé pour moi
grâce à elle je commençais à me sentir
mieux à me sentir appartenir à un milieu
et là je repensais à ces fameux s'est
inquiété de la cantine
comprenez-moi bien j'avais grandi
entouré de plusieurs nationalités et
j'adorais ça mais pour la première fois
depuis toutes ces années je me
retrouvais parmi les miens est ce que je
ressentais ne s'expliquait pas en plus
de ça ce que je ne vous dis pas ces
personnes que je rencontre et étaient
des personnes brillantes
à commencer par mon ami lui même des
étudiants dans de prestigieuses
universités des personnes d'y occuper
des postes de cadre à hautes
responsabilités dans de très grandes
entreprises des entrepreneurs qui
traversaient les états unis pour vendre
leurs produits et services
en voyant ça je suis passé par plusieurs
états au début j'étais scotché scotché
et admiratif de voir que des noirs de
surcroît des burkinabè pouvait atteindre
ce niveau socioprofessionnel
en france d'où je venais je n'avais
jamais vu pas qu'il n'en existait pas
mais je n'en connaissais clairement pas
ensuite j'ai été inspiré à ouais je me
suis dit ça y est tu veux être comme
quand je serai grand et c'est à ce
moment là que j'ai compris l'importance
d'avoir des modèles de réussite autour
de soi et pour moi c'était des burkinabè
après ça j'étais en colère je ne saurais
vous dire contre qui ni contre quoi mais
j'étais en colère je ne comprenais pas
pourquoi ces personnes aussi brillante
qu'elle soit n'étaient pas connues de
tous et surtout pourquoi est ce qu'elle
faisait pas des choses ensemble à la fin
là j'étais au bord de l'implosion
je suis demandé mais où étaient toutes
ces personnes lorsque je cherchais mon
stage non mais sérieusement vous
imaginez tout aurait changé pour moi
aujourd'hui j'aurais été comme eux et là
j'ai encore beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir
durant ma résidence aux états unis je me
suis mis encore plus voyager gars comme
vous je voulais dit j'adore les voyages
j'ai eu la chance de visiter le panama
où la chaleur humaine de ses habitants
le rappeler celle du burkinabè en chine
la fierté et la forte de travail les
chinois aiment à rappeler celle de mon
ethnie gourmande chez les enfants qui
jouaient dans les townships de soweto en
afrique du sud m'ont rappelé mon enfance
ici même à ouaga à la cité an iii
j'adore voyager parce qu'à chaque fois
je découvre de nouveaux endroits aussi
magnifiques les uns que les autres mais
aussi parce que je fais de nouvelles
rencontres et donc de nouvelles
inspirations
je me suis beaucoup inspiré des
personnes qui étaient très actives dans
leur communauté et surtout très ancré à
leurs racines plus je m'évadais à
travers ses voyages plus je ressentais
le besoin de me rapprocher de mes
racines je dépense est tellement fort
que la vie m'a offert une opportunité
j'ai eu le choix
entre rester aux etats-unis consolider
une situation très confortable en plus
dans la finance ou alors saisir une
opportunité au burkina faso vous savez
lorsque vous évoluez dans ces pays que
vous en respecter les codes et les
règles ils font tout pour garder
peu importe vous venez surtout aux états
unis
il est vrai que j'ai été tenté d'y
rester mais malgré tout ce que ce pays
avait à offrir à la fin du jour je
voulais juste être chez moi et depuis
que je le suis je veux être dues par
ailleurs toute cette période
depuis mon arrivée en france on
déracinement mon échec au bac
ma solitude dans mon ascension
professionnelle mais voyage jusqu'à marc
connexion avec le burkina et les
burkinabè avait fait naître en moi
quelque chose de très fort je m'étais
mis à rêver d'un concept qui viendraient
remédier à tous mes mots et solutionner
toutes ces problématiques que j'avais
vécu et identifiés cependant j'ai été
interpellé par deux choses la première
c'est que je n'étais pas sûre que ce
concept allait avoir un impact au delà
de ma seule personne et ensuite je
voyais tellement grand que je ne pouvais
pas le réaliser seul je rêvais de
pouvoir naviguer dans un monde où à
chaque instant peu importe l'endroit où
je me trouve je puisse me reconnecter
avec mes racines je rêvais de pouvoir
créer des connexions avec les autres en
leur offrant des opportunités qui
changerait à jamais leur vie je rêvais
de pouvoir bénéficier de l'expérience
des uns et des autres afin d'orienter et
de donner un sens à ma vie en fait je
rêvais de ne plus être seul peu importe
l'endroit où je me trouve ce rêve
est devenu réalité grâce à la rencontre
de quatre magnifiques personnes quatre
magnifiques personnes avec lesquelles
sommes partis à l'aventuré cette
aventure avait pour but de réunir un
maximum de burkinabè à travers le monde
leur permet de se rencontrer d'échanger
des opportunités de partager leurs
expériences et ultimement de faire des
choses ensemble
au début nous étions 5 aujourd'hui nous
sommes bientôt 2000 par embrasser ce
concept est présent sur les cinq
continents
nous avons permis à plus d'un millier de
personnes de se rencontrer à travers une
quinzaine d'événements que nous avons
organisés en europe en afrique et en
amérique du nord
nous avons permis à près d'une centaine
de personnes de trouver des emplois à
travers le monde notamment en afrique de
l'ouest et encore plus au burkina une
dizaine de sociétés a également vu le
jour à travers toutes ces rencontres
tout cela sans contrepartie si c'était
celle de rester ensemble
à travers ces événements nous avons
réalisé le potentiel professionnel des
burkinabè et des opportunités
florissante au burkina nous sommes rendu
compte que nous n'étions pas seuls à se
sentir isolé et que chacun d'entre nous
avaient besoin de l'autre pour évoluer
nous étions convaincus qu'à travers des
efforts conjugués nous pourrions nous
pouvions participer un développement
collectif
voilà pourquoi nous avons créé cette
organisation à but non lucratif
apolitique est ouverte à tous qui
apporte aujourd'hui des solutions
endogènes et innovantes aux
problématiques que nous vivons en
faisant appel à nos racines et à la
cohésion humaine
nous avons réussi à créer une véritable
communauté d'étudiants et de jeunes
actifs burkinabè mais pas qu'eux qui est
autour du et connectés les uns aux
autres ce concept dont je rêvais a donc
vu le jour grâce un travail d équipe et
j'insiste sur ce point grâce à un
travail d'équipé et grandi aujourd'hui
grâce à des personnes comme vous qui
avez envie de faire les choses ensemble
après je suis donc de retour au burkina
la reconnexion avec le burkina et les
burkinabè était comme un appel naturel
pour moi une sorte de ré découverte de
qui j'étais un privilégié c'est ainsi
que je me considère privilégié d'avoir
eu ce parcours est de pouvoir l'utiliser
afin de créer de réaliser mes rêves
cette histoire c'est la mienne mais vous
avez également la vôtre et peut-être
vous sera t-elle à vous engager pour
votre commune ou pour votre communauté
et pourquoi pas réaliser vos rêves
burkinabè ou non africains ou non si ce
soir vous doutez encore de la puissance
de vos racines
j'espère qu'à la fin de cette soirée ce
ne sera plus le cas
j'aime à penser que ce n'est pas
forcément l'endroit où l'on se trouve
qui détermine notre bien être et notre
bonheur est plutôt les personnes avec
qui l'on est
néanmoins nous restons le produit de
notre adn et je suis intimement
convaincu que l'accomplissement de soi
passe par la reconnexion avec nos
racines
c'est ce qui nous ce qui nous rendra
conscient de ce que nous étions et je
pense que thomas fiers de ce que nous
sommes merci audrey d'avoir assisté sur
ce point est meilleur pour l'avenir
la puissance des racines m'a fait
réaliser qu'en vérité je n'étais jamais
parti de chez moi et je n'avais pas
vraiment quitté les nerfs mais sans ses
voyages je n'aurais jamais réalisée et
je ne serais certainement pas devant
vous ce soir aux plus jeunes
j'aimerais vous dire de voyager sans
retenue car les voyages nous éduque mais
n'oubliez jamais d'où vous venez
c'est ce qui vous rendre ce qui vous
permettra d'accomplir grands mais
surtout d'accomplir juste j'aimerais
vous dire de ne jamais vous laisser
diviser car c'est notre plus grand frein
en tant qu'africain seul vous pourrez
démarrer mais ensemble vous y arriverez
à coup sûr à tout
soyons les multiples branches de ce même
et unique arbres aux racines profondes
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]